The vast majority of the human genome is
actually made up of non coding sequences. In fact,
less than 2% of our genetic code is
actually information that codes for proteins. Now for some
people this could actually be rather shocking, and
a lot or research in the scientific community has
gone into figuring out what that other 98% does.
A recent report by the Encode project or the
encyclopedia of DNA elements have revealed that up
to 80% of our human Genome is involved in
some sort of roller activity through binding the proteins
and regulating gene expressing even the production of other
types of RNA that aren't ultimately turned into protein.
This means that the vast majority of our genomic
information doesn't actually code for the physical stuff that
makes up who we are, but instead regulates the
expression of the coding parts, so that they're
turned on at the right time and the
right place. After all, that's what's most important
in the recipe after we define our ingredients.